making money isn't difficult you want to
know what the difficult part is keeping
the money I know a kid he made $10
million in The nft Craze okay so he
cashed out into ethereum and he had $10
million in E couple years later he is
worth
$10,000 where did it all go so he got
paid in ethereum when ethereum was worth
$3,000 he got greedy he didn't sell and
so he wrode the whole thing down and
sold when eth was at
$1,200 that's what like 70% of his net
worth just gone he also spent money on
bottle service clubs girls cars
investing in more crypto scams and
things like that and so you can ride $10
million all the way down to zero very
easily so the hard part and the real
skill comes in when it comes to money is
how do you keep it how do you have
discipline in your life so that you
don't waste money on Lambos and waste
money on yachts and women and girls and
clubs and tables that's the hard part
it's the discipline